quand un client appelle à la clinique
vétérinaire touche à tout pour faire
dégriffer son chat la réponse du
personnel est toujours la même
la docteure france tancelin refusent de
pratiquer cette chirurgie depuis environ
cinq ans parce que le lendemain matin je
les voyais se réveiller puis je les
voyais dans la cage puis je les voyais
souffrir malgré tout les antidouleurs
qu'on leur donne et puis un moment donné
j'ai décidé que c'était fini sandra
desjardin à considérer faire dégriffer
son chat jusqu'à ce qu'on lui explique
en quoi consiste l'intervention c'est
pas juste les griffes qui enlève y
enlève le bout du doigt au complet alors
j'ai refusé la spc est de montréal parle
d'une chirurgie inhumaine c'est
l'équivalent de m'amputer le dernier la
dernière phalange de chacun des douanes
en force n 7 a marché dessus
l'organisme a mis en ligne une pétition
mardi matin pour faire pression sur
l'ordre des médecins vétérinaires du
québec afin qu'ils interdisent cette
pratique l'ordre reconnaît que cette
procédure qui coûte entre 150 et 300
dollars n'est pas médicalement
nécessaires sa présidente estime que bon
nombre des 1500 vétérinaire qui soigne
des animaux de compagnie ne font plus
cette opération elle préconise
l'éducation plutôt que l'interdiction
c'est une chirurgie qui ait pu montrer à
la faculté de médecine vétérinaire des
plus enseignée et on leur enseigne pas
non plus elle proposait la spc a et
l'ordre s'entendent sur un point il
existe des solutions de rechange ou
dégriffage par exemple la coupe
régulière des griffes
on peut pas priver l'animal s'était de
son intégrité
parce qu'on un divan tués à mon avis il
faut choisir cette chirurgie est déjà
interdite dans quatre provinces
canadiennes et une trentaine de pays
dans le monde ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal